in the early 1990s director James
Cameron convinced Carroll killed
pictures which produced movies such as
Terminator 2 Total Recall and Rambo 2
option the film rights to spider-man but
Cameron's production was ultimately
tangled in an inescapable lead why
couldn't one of Hollywood's most
powerful directors get this film made no
too edgy
Cameron's plans for spider-man have
become a Hollywood legend according to
Rebecca Keegan's booked the Futurist
life in films of James Cameron Spidey
creator Stan Lee absolutely loved
cameras treatment ultimately many of
Cameron's own ideas like Spidey's
organic web shooters and Uncle Ben's
carjacking death made it into the Sam
Raimi directed spider-man movie from
2002 but for every one of Cameron's good
ideas there were at least three that
were not Cameron called for Peter to
curse like a sailor which would have
resulted in an r-rating and then there
was a scene where Peter peeped in Mary
Jane's window is she dressed and one
more Spidey and MJ get intimate on the
Brooklyn Bridge while Peter describes
the creepy way spiders made what
low budget Cameron would have likely
made spider-man right after Terminator 2
which had a 100 million dollar budget
according to Janet wass goes how
Hollywood works Carroll Co only
committed to a 50 million dollar budget
a huge step backwards for him and at the
reported budgets of his next two films
100 million for True Lies and a
record-setting 200 million for Titanic
tell us anything that Spidey's balance
sheet wasn't going to fly bad casting
rumor has it that Cameron wanted to cast
Arnold Schwarzenegger as Doctor Octopus
Schwarzenegger even hinted his
involvement in an interview with Empire
only going so far as to vaguely say that
the studio went in another direction
there are yet more rumors and reports of
Cameron stream cash in the film and one
of them is a pretty strange choice
Edward Furlong whose big break came as
John Connor and Cameron's Terminator 2
was reportedly the director's pick for
Peter Parker and Leonardo DiCaprio is to
play Harry Osborn of course Leo wouldn't
play second fiddle to just anyone
Johnny Depp sure Eddie furlong not a
chance
the report also pegs Drew Barrymore is
gwen stacy and j jonah Jameson would
have been played by r lee ermey the
drill sergeant and Full Metal Jacket you
won't laugh it will not cry you will
learn by the number I won't treat you
that would have been perfect but it
wouldn't have been enough to make up for
taking the principal cast litigation
while the script casting and budget
issues all could have become later
stumbling blocks but ultimately squashed
Cameron spider-man weren't legal issues
Cameron told Collider that when Carroll
Co collapsed a few years after they
acquired the rights to spider-man he
already had Titanic in his sights
moreover he no longer wanted to pursue
spider-man because of all the competing
interest for the rights
amid Carroll coasts bankruptcy and
Marvel's apparently a number of former
writers and producers all claim to have
had a hand in developing the project and
they all came calling marvel's own 1996
bankruptcy process scattered multiple
holding deals the wind according to how
Hollywood works after Marvel recovered
from bankruptcy it basically paid off
everyone who was trying to sue for the
rights of spider-man which free them up
to sell the rights to Sony
meanwhile Cameron turned one of the
greatest human tragedies of all time
into a billion-dollar smash so he did
just fine on the Keawe
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
who should have starred in James Cameron
spider-man movie